.
Mathieu Prost.
- Alors c'est pour ça
que je suis là.
- L'image est symbolique :
trois catrois candidats et une e
vide. C'était lors du dernier
débat local dans
la circonscription
de Camille-Laurin.
Marie-Ève Rancourt, de Québec
solidaire, venait de se retirer
de la course parce qu'elle avait
un peu plus tôt retiré
un dépliant du Parti québécois
d'une boîte aux lettres.
Un revirement digne
d'une surprise d'octobre,
comme on les appelle dans
les campagnes présidentielles
américaines, selon cette
électrice, qui a finalement
voté PQ.
- Capoté! Complètement
inattendu, qui change
complètement la donne chez nous.
Je pense que M. Campeau doit
se sentir moins sécure.
- Je m'appelle Richard Campeau,
je suis votre député provincial,
membre de la CAQ.
- En 2018, il avait arraché
cette circonscription
au Parti québécois par 500 voix
sur 50 000 électeurs.
Aujourd'hui, avec une candidate
de moins sur l'échiquier et
des électeurs devenus orphelins
à moins d'une semaine
du scrutin...
RICHARD CAMPEAU, candidat, CAQ
Camille-Laurin
- Pour moi, ça change pas grand-
chose. On continue à rencontrer
les gens individuellement,
faire du porte-à-porte,
rien prendre pour acquis.
- Car on trouve de tout
chez les électeurs solidaires.
- Je vais réfléchir encore.
Est-ce que je ne voterai plus?
Parce que quand même,
on est déçus? Bah, je dirais,
je garderais le même, l'ancien.
- C'est-à-dire?
- Monsieur Legault.
- Des transferts vers la CAQ
donc, mais aussi...
- Je sais que la politique,
c'est peut-être pas toujours
clean, mais j'aime pas ça,
une attitude comme ça.
Donc j'ai décidé de voter
pour le PQ.
- Et des glissements vers
Paul St-Pierre Plamondon,
qui pourrait bénéficier
d'une prime au chef.
- Je suis un électeur de la CAQ.
Si c'était pas PSP, je voterais
CAQ. On veut PSP
dans le comté.
- On va ramener les seuils
en proportion de notre capacité
d'accueil.
- Est-ce qu'il sent
un frémissement en sa faveur,
lui dont les performances
aux débats ont été soulignées?
PAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chef, Parti québécois
- Je pense que les gens ont
suivi. Ils ont suivi les débats,
ils sont intéressés.
Quand je marche dans le comté,
les gens interviennent,
ils baissent leur fenêtre, ils
font des saluts, ça klaxonne.
- La candidate libérale,
elle aussi, pourrait profiter
d'un report de voix
des solidaires.
CHRISTINA EYANGOS, candidate,
PLQ Camille-Laurin
- J'ai toujours parlé de justice
sociale, du communautaire,
de la place du communautaire,
et comment l'économie et
le communautaire, les deux,
sont reliés et non...
c'est pas en opposition.
- Dans un secteur
qui s'embourgeoise et où
les logements se font plus rares
et chers, surtout pour
les familles, les électeurs
s'attendent à des résultats.
À l'échelle de la province,
la CAQ prévoit construire
12 000 logements sociaux; c'est
50 000 pour Québec solidaire
et le Parti libéral;
35 000 pour le PQ.
- Il y a des gens qui pourraient
se demander : "Pourquoi 12 000,
pourquoi pas 50 000?"
Il y a une question
de capacité de construire.
- On nous dit du côté de la CAQ:
"Ah, mais c'est impossible
de les bâtir, il n'y a pas
de main-d'oeuvre." Mais c'est
drôle, pour un troisième lien
à Québec, ça, par contre,
il semble y en avoir,
de la main-d'oeuvre!
- Autre dossier chaud dans
la circonscription : le projet
de Ray-Mont Logistiques,
- Le ou la prochaine élue
devra aussi faire passer le test
d'acceptabilité sociale au futur
REM de l'Est, qui traversera
la circonscription